when the culture wars started kicking
off I just started asking myself is this
actually useful ooh all these ideas
sound awesome but there's something that
tells me there's a problem lurking
within living in California I began to
realize I don't know what metric we're
using but yikes it isn't human
flourishing and if something sounds good
but it doesn't work you have to
immediately change course and so I began
to realize in the culture war in life in
general in a marriage everything it's a
d Dynamic tension between two opposing
views and by having the dynamic tension
you make
progress Tom last time I was here you
were interviewing me and within about 3
seconds of meeting you I was like dude I
love your mind and you are a guy who's
into growth into building and yet we
were having a conversation about culture
wars and woke culture how did you how
are you here oo on that topic yeah so
how are you trigonometry well that's a
really interesting question this is
surreal for me this is uh this is a fun
show to be on so I come from a place of
actually believing that the only thing
that's different between me and somebody
that hasn't achieved the kind of success
that they want is a set of ideas once
you realize it's a set of ideas that is
the difference between success and
failure you get pretty obsessed with
trying to get those ideas across to
people if you really want to see other
people shine which I do that's just my
thing uh and so when the culture wars
started kicking off I just started
asking myself is this actually useful
will this help somebody's life be better
if an idea will help somebody's life be
better I'm going to get behind it I'm
going to Champion it if it is an idea
that subtly feels right but is going to
move your life backwards then I get very
worried and when this all started
kicking off I was like oo all these
ideas sound awesome but there's
something that tells me there's a
problem lurking within and so I really
came at it feeling ignorant cuz I was
like I'm having a hard time making sense
of these incredibly complicated topics
but I have a gut feeling that there's a
problem and so in working through that
and really trying to figure out what do
I think about this stuff why does this
feel wrong when it sounds so right uh
and then the the um Thomas Soul quote
really became like an obsession of mine
he said this 20 years ago so I'll just
switch the number out for the difference
for today I said the last 50 years have
been marked by exchanging what worked
for what sounds good and I was like oh
my God that's exactly what's happening
is people are not thinking about hey I
have a hypothesis I think if we do this
thing it will yield this result and we
have a Northstar of human flourishing
let's say maybe we don't agree on that
but you need a Northstar and you need a
metric by which you're going to judge
whether you've achieved that Northstar
it's like business 101 and and living in
California I began to realize I don't
know what metric we're using but yikes
it isn't human flourishing so that just
started to all come together and I was
like okay I need to actually understand
this what are the ideas where are they
becoming um problematic why why do they
sound good but not yield good results
like where does all this break down
because I've worked in the inner cities
a lot and so I really have seen people
get eaten alive by their zip code there
really is a problem very smart people
meet very dumb ideas and it completely
ruins their life and so the idea of like
wanting to help people that are in a bad
situation is the thrust of my life
that's what I want to do but as an
entrepreneur I'm like you have to have a
metric to know if you're actually making
progress and if something sounds good
but it doesn't work you have to
immediately change course so then I get
into stop me if I go like if if you have
anything but uh I start thinking about
okay why do we B for into left and right
like what is that because the ideas
sound awesome because they're coming
from a place of compassion okay but is
compassion always good or does it fall
on a spectrum of pathology on one side
and maybe help in the middle and then
pathology again on the other side and so
I began to realize that in the culture
war in life in general in a marriage
everything it's a dynamic tension
between two opposing views and by having
the dynamic tension you make progress if
you don't have Dynamic tension then you
go to pathology and so if you think of
the left and right divide there's
pathology on both sides so you can be
pathologically left you can be
pathologically right they look different
but it's the same unchecked just sort of
where this runs Riot on my Tombstone my
wife has very strict instructions to
write the words you're having a
biological
experience and the reason that I want
that on my Tombstone is that that like
if I make that contribution to the world
I'll be very happy if I just get people
to understand that that's it your
everything in your life is seen through
the lens of the way your brain works the
way eyes work ears work so on and so
forth and so effectively you are living
in a simulation created by your biology
and none of us know what is objectively
true we're only able to perceive
0.35% of the available electromagnetic
spectrum and we confuse that with all
there is to see but in reality of course
it's just all we can see so once I
realize that then you start thinking
about emotions and you start going okay
we have these emotions they feel real
they convince us to act a certain way
but are they real what does real mean
all of that so anyway as I break that
down and I ask as a species we become
the most dominant apex predator the
world has ever seen we're doing
something right you've all know Harari
talks about our ability not just to
gather in groups but to do so flexibly
and to do so around ideology and ideas
and so that just got me thinking about
left and right okay cool so is it
possible then that left and right
represent something biological and they
both represent something valuable
biological and we happen to be moving
through a time where it's becoming
pathologized which would take the whole
episode to sort of stream together all
the ways that I think that happens but
if you'll grant me that that we're in a
moment of pathology something is broken
it's going wrong what becomes the
oversimplified fix for me is born out of
understanding why the left and right
exist in the human psyche if I know I'm
having a biological experience that has
yielded the most effective animal the
world has ever seen okay so I'm coming
at it from that stance and I say to
myself okay uh if the left is compassion
compassion's awesome I love it the most
I want more compassion if the right is
call it self- responsibility I love it
the most I want more personal
responsibility and so I'm like why have
we bifurcated such that it really does
seem split almost exactly down the
middle that and of course it's a
spectrum and so I'm not saying
everybody's hard in One Direction or
another but like those two really do
seem to sum up the way that people
lean so then using my marriage as a
analogy I was like okay I learned very
early on in my marriage that I didn't
want to change my wife into thinking
like me I needed to distrust myself and
I needed to say I'm not going to pretend
I don't feel this way but I'm not going
to pretend I know I'm right so I'm just
going to say uh probably the reason that
men and women have thrived so long is
that they really do see things very
differently and it becomes the dynamic
tension between the two that yields good
results I can go into a whole diet tribe
about coming of age rituals which I
think are very missing they why I got a
tattoo and I got married I wanted to
ritualistically scar myself to really go
through something to be like I'm
different now but anyway going in my
marriage I have been served by this
Dynamic tension is it possible that we
need a dynamic tension between the left
and the right that we need them both we
have to Value them both but something
has happened that has weakened one side
and made the other side stronger such
that now things tip into pathology on
one side I will take the what will on
your channel not be controversial but on
many channels it be very controversial
stance so what's happened is we've let
compassion become pathologized and
it's so hard to push back on if you're
wired anything like me because all the
ideas sound amazing and they sound like
the same kind of ideas that I'm
dedicating my life to and for people
that have never heard of impact Theory
my whole thing is that I have a theory
that if you can get ideas into the hands
of people growing up in the inner cities
that those ideas will change the
trajectory of their life so it's like
you would think that then I would spill
to the left but as a business person I'm
like yeah but you have to judge the
Merit of an idea based entirely on its
efficacy and I driving down La you just
see homeless people literally everywhere
uh so it's like okay something isn't
working I don't know what that something
is I just know something isn't working
and so now you have to start to ask
questions and then that's the first
thing you realize is being a SED is ah
like there are certain questions you
can't ask so then I become like re like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa like if it's
the dynamic tension between the two and
again maybe I'm wrong but this is my
belief if it's the Dynam tension the
second you ask one group to shut up you
create the pathology and so now you've
got social media which spreads ideas
very rapidly the left their ideas just
sound better they sound Kinder they
sound more loving they sound like what
we should all aspire to the problem is
just going left doesn't actually work if
it did I'd be all for it remember I know
my Northstar it is human flourishing for
as many people as humanly possible so
it's like okay cool does going Only One
Direction yield human flourishing yes or
no that you can test this no it does not
not on the right not on the left so now
and I've seen this play out in business
as well in fact I'll speak to you guys
as business partners gentlemen I would
like to make an appeal there are going
to be times where you both think the
other person is an outright [__] and
you can't believe you've been business
partners as long as you have and in that
moment you need to distrust yourself far
more than the other person and you need
to say the very thing that will make
this relationship work is that we see
the world in a slightly different way
and the fact that we see it differently
means we will have fewer blind spots and
so we need to respect the dynamic
tension you get this all the time
between a CEO and a COO and if either
one of them thinks the other as a [__]
so a CEO is visionary a COO is
implementation if the implementor is
annoyed at the dreamer you're going to
have a problem and if the dreamer is
annoyed that these things actually have
to be implemented you're going to have a
problem you need them both so to use the
analogy of a kite and a string if you
have a kite with no string it flies off
into nothing crashes into a tree and
gets ruined if you have a string with no
kite it lays on the ground you need a
string and a kite in Dynamic tension to
hold something aoft and so my whole
thing about the culture war is I started
feeling like a coward because I was not
speaking about things that I felt like
oo I can see that this is going wrong
this is not going to lead to human
flourishing but I don't want anybody to
ruin my YouTube channel that I've worked
so hard to build and I'm trying to get
into video games God do I want people
thinking about me on these controversial
topics and then I was like uh all that
it takes for evil to flourish is for
good men to do nothing so I thought okay
I'm being quiet out of cowardice I don't
like feeling like a coward and so here
we are with me on trigonometry it is so
amazing because I think what you've
summed up there is actually the ethos of
why we started what we started the the
difference is it's that fight club court
it's it's only once you've lost
everything think that you're free to do
anything that was our issue we didn't
have anything to
lose but for you it's different now in
terms of the the practicality of these
ideas I agree with you it seems like we
are now living in a world that is
entirely
driven by what sounds good why don't we
course correct why is that not happened
why do people who live in California not
drive down the highway and see homeless
encampments and go
H maybe what we're doing isn't
working okay so there are a lot of
reasons we'll try to tease them out one
at a time so reason number one is that
these ideas are very nuanced very
nuanced
and the human mind has a very hard time
conceptualizing a nuanced argument and
even if they can get it it's hard to
remember and so they'll use a heuristic
to make it easier and so they'll boil it
down into a bumper sticker mhm now the
problem is the bumper sticker is where
the pathology begins because now it's
like um uh no man left behind Okay I
love that it's an awesome idea and if I
were in the Marines maybe but also you
can just feed people to a sniper trying
to go get the person who's wounded and
so um you'll see this in school systems
where they I don't know if they have
this so I come from Washington State
they have something called mcken vento
and it's literally no Child Left Behind
and they will drive a bus 2 three hours
out of their way to go and get the kid
and bring them back and I'm just like
whoa I get the sentiment I really get
the sentiment but I don't know that it
plays out well I haven't looked at that
closely enough to stake my thing on I'm
just using that as an example of where
you take something so far to the extreme
you're not willing to let anything like
fall through the cracks now you're no
longer prioritizing or you just
recognize that now becomes the priority
and in reality everything is going to be
a give and take there's going to be no
perfect solution there are no Utopias
only tradeoffs that's a paraphrase of
not exact quote of Thomas Soul again
there Solutions only tradeoffs perfect
so everything is going to be a give and
take like ah if we do this then we're
going to get this second or third order
consequence which is not ideal but if we
don't we end up in this dark place so
okay now you combine that reality with
people are having a hard time wrapping
their own head around a very nuanced
very compx licated idea myself included
man again I come to this cuz I really
struggled in the beginning to figure out
why it felt wrong when it sounded so
right so I think a lot of people exist
in that they're given a bumper sticker
and certain bumper stickers sound way
better than others like when I tell
people this is where I really get myself
in trouble okay I once wrote A Blog
article and that blog article when I
wrote it I was giddy man this is back
before I had a YouTube channel nothing
and I thought okay the idea that has
made me me very successful is a really
simple idea and I turned it into a
T-shirt and everything and my t-shirt
says everything is my
fault and
bro people did not like that idea so I
wrote this article that said hey I want
you to imagine I get hit by a drunk
driver whose fault is that and I'm like
I know all of you right now even
insurance companies are saying that it's
the drunk driver's fault and I'm like no
it's my fault I chose to get into the
car I had laid this whole thing out I
chose to get in a car I chose to put
myself in a position where I couldn't go
forward or sideways or get out I set it
up such the horn didn't work all this
stuff I didn't take care of my car all
of those things I could have done
differently so yes I get why other
people will say it's a drunk driver's
fault but now you're taking away my
power because I could have done
something different and got a different
result and so I would for the next time
say I want to make sure since I can't
control his behavior that I prep myself
to be able to do something different and
get that different result now
I honestly thought I'm going to publish
this people are going to write and say
Tom oh my God you just changed my life
this is amazing thank you so much and
the feedback was vitriolic you're victim
blaming how dare you this is horrible
and I was like really I was legitimately
confused and I thought but hold on a
second if you take responsibility for
your life your life is going to be
better by every metric I can possibly
think of your mental health will be
better CU you'll never feel like a
victim you will feel like okay it sucks
that this happened to me but I can now
do something I can decide I want to do
something else and and make good on my
life I can uh one of my favorite songs
from when I was a kid was called best I
can by Queens Reich mad love Queens
Reich shout out uh and the song is about
a kid who accidentally shoots himself
and becomes paralyzed and decides I'm
still going to do the best I can and I'm
GNA maybe I'm not going to play sports
but I'm going to become a magazine
editor and I'm going to blow up that way
and that really spoke to me even as a
kid I was just like oh word like even if
something bad happens to me I'm always
going to do the best I can and so I'm
just like wait what's your North Star
and so I often will lead with that when
people are saying something that doesn't
make sense I want to if I'm completely
honest I want to trap them by saying
what they want and then I'm like okay
what do you want by what metric will you
judge it write it down and now you have
a hypothesis if I do this um
let people put tents up wherever they
want uh don't arrest people for doing
drugs out of compassion uh but the thing
that I will get is happiness fewer
homeless people less people incarcerated
whatever metric and then if we can agree
on that then we just look and say did
that work were there second and third
order consequences that we didn't
anticipate do they outweigh the first
order consequence of whatever and cool
now we're talking about the metrics
we're talking about the things that we
tested and then we're saying did they
work or not but people don't write down
what they think is going to happen and
so they make it up in their mind that
yeah yeah yeah that's roughly what I
thought would happen um or they'll just
default to this is too complicated or
whatever whatever whatever but they're
not holding themselves accountable so my
whole thing is like hey because my
Northstar is your life being better
happier more love in your life um better
mental health making more money all of
it like the whole kitten Kaboodle that
is a well optimized human life I'm just
looking at that going accountability is
the thing it it's the thing and so if
you don't have that you will blow with
the Winds of chance and you will live
your life by accident if you take
responsibility for everything and say my
life is an exact reflection of my
choices even when that hurts you still
have an Avenue to get better to me what
we're talking about a lot here is
deferred gratification to it's actually
saying I'm not going to pick the thing
that's easy which is to blame someone
else I'm going to do the thing that's
more difficult which is to have interest
inection look not only at my actions but
my thought processes and my overall
worldview in order to
improve there's a lot of people who
don't want to do that because it's not
easy I don't think they get that far so
I think the biggest problem people have
is what they build their self-esteem
around the number one problem we will
all face in life is do I respect
myself I will venture that most people
Cobble self-respect together through the
echo instead of the shout what I mean by
that is humans no matter what they tell
you no matter if they say they don't
care about what other people think they
care about what other people think we
are a social creature now the thing that
you may get people thinking about you in
the way that you want them to think
about you is by pushing back and not
caring about people's feelings and all
that but it's nested inside of that's
how I earn my place in the group you
still care very deeply about earning
your place in the group so if you're
trying to earn your your place in the
group and you earn it through loving
acceptance by I have the right beliefs
that are I mean let's even say that
they're positive I have the right
beliefs by showing how much I love
people and I care about people and I
stand for the right causes and I I don't
say that cynically I mean you're really
doing your best to be a good person and
that's how you're gaining acceptance
that's all the echo it's not the what
are you actually doing like what are you
doing to earn your respect so I believe
that comes from you have a value system
and you live in accordance with your
values most people do not map their
values they don't know what they are and
if you don't know what you value now
again you're left to the whims of are
other people telling me I'm a good
person and if they are telling me I'm a
good person and this is the bad news
they'll really believe it so I really do
have self-respect because other people
tell me that they respect me cool now I
feel good about myself but the thing
that they're actually getting laed for
is having the right opinions and now
they're trapped because they can't think
through hard problems because they run
the risk of losing their own Respect by
losing the respect of others because
they are a slave to the echo if on the
other hand you build your self-esteem
around the shout the things that I do
whether they work or not now you've
really got a chance because it's it's
respect that's truly emanating from
within now the only thing I have found
that is a safe way to build your
self-esteem around internally is to be
the learner because if you build it
around being right being smart being
Worthy being loved being good all of
those things that people try to build
their self-esteem around they're very
fragile and this is why and I think
people on the right take a little too
much joy when people on the left eat
their own is that that that's brutal to
go through and to watch people you know
sort of do that downward spiral if you
can instead say I don't know that I'm
going to get it right I just know I'm
going to learn from it and the very
thing I'm going to Value myself for is
my will willingness to stare nakedly at
my own inadequacies okay cool now you're
in a position if you tell me I'm stupid
that's going to damage most people's
self-esteem because they value
themselves for being right for being
smart for getting positive feedback from
an outside group I'm on the other hand
and I'm not going to say it doesn't
sting I'm still a human I still want
people to think I'm cool I still like to
be right the first time that's always
the most fun uh but immediately I'm
going to go ooh tell me more I'm not
going to run away from that I'm not
going to try to hide from that cuz I'm
thinking to myself wait I've got gotten
this far by being wrong if you can
really remove a scale from my eye and
look I'm not a fool if you tell me
something that doesn't match up with my
life experience or what I have mapped
the world to to really be true then I'm
going to say I really appreciate your
feedback because that will ensure that I
get more in the future uh I disagree I
disagree for this reason right so I'm
not just like oh my God tell me what I
need to believe but I really do open my
heart up to this person may be about to
tell me something that will make me more
effective cuz this is what I call true
power true power is the ability to close
your eyes imagine a world better than
this one open your eyes acquire the
skills that you would need to actually
make that world come true and then have
the fortitude and the delayed
gratification to actually make it come
true that's power that's what my life is
about so I'm just running through that
whole circle to see if um I'm doing
things the way that I should so to get
back to that core idea if people are
building their self-esteem
around something
external they just they are so going to
protect themselves from feeling badly
about themselves they don't ever get any
farther than that they're going to
reject any idea that makes them feel
badly about themselves and that might be
the primary reaction that we all have as
a social creature is we're trying to
figure out where we fall in the
hierarchy and self-esteem is is one very
good guide which is why as you go lower
down your self-esteem drops there's
they're correlated in some way you'll
have to have somebody Smarter on to
explain how and why but like I know that
they are and so as you go down the
hierarchy you start feeling worse about
yourself okay so now we've got the
psychological immune system which is
that part of your brain that makes it
everybody else's fault and so the reason
I think people say no no no it's not my
fault is they have to say it's not their
fault to maintain their self-esteem
because they are building it on external
feedback coming in the Echo and not the
shout whereas somebody who's done the
work to say my self-esteem is built
entirely around my willingness to stare
nakedly at my inadequacies that I can be
laughed at longer than somebody else I
don't mind making mistakes because I
learn from them and that's what I value
myself for that person when attacked
they actually get stronger and it
becomes a truly antifragile identity but
I don't I think they say that uh all of
life's problems are man's inability to
sit alone in a room by himself I think
it might be a slight variation on that
which is people can't be laughed at they
can't have other people think they're
stupid because their self-esteem
requires it and they will fight
subconsciously they're not even aware of
it they'll fight subconsciously against
any idea that attacks their sense of
self or
self-esteem we'll get back to the
episode in a minute but first we want to
tell you about our sponsor fume if you
want to break your bad habit you can
forget about having to go cold turkey
there's now a better way we're talking
about fume it's spelled Fu M and
pronounced fume which makes no sense
anyway not everything in a bad habit is
wrong so instead of a dramatic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit fume is an
Innovative award-winning flavored air
device that does just that you can trade
breathing in nasty chemicals for
breathing in Fresh Air instead of vapor
fume uses flavored Air instead of
electronics fume is completely natural
and instead of harmful chemicals fume
uses delicious flavors it's a habit
you're free to enjoy joy and makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable parts and
magnets for fidgeting which gives your
finger something to do which is helpful
for de-stressing and anxiety while
breaking your bad habit I'll be honest I
wasn't sure what to expect with fume but
they're actually more flavorful than I
thought and it actually feels fresh the
feel of them is nice it's well weighted
perfectly balanced and they're made from
real wood which feels nice and looks
great too fume has served over 150,000
customers and has thousands of success
stories there's no reason that can't be
you join fume in accelerating Humanity's
breakup from destructive Habits by
picking up the journey pack today head
to trif nume.com and use code trig to
save 10% off when you get the journey
pack today that's try
f.com and use code trig T to save an
additional 10% off your order today give
it a go it might just help you kick that
bad habit back to the
interview you've just summed it up
perfectly it's beautifully the way that
you've just said that to me this is
these are the kind of lessons actually
that a father should teach a son or a
daughter to me when I hear that that is
what every father should teach their kid
so I guess my question to you is do you
think that the reason we're experiencing
these these crisises
is we have an absence of fathers at in
the home it's interesting so I think
that's going to be a huge part of it but
maybe for a slightly different reason so
I'll say that's a dynamic tension
problem because if we only had father
fathers and no mothers we'd have an
equally pathological Society it would
just be in a different direction so you
want that Dynamic tension between the
two of them but yes we need to be
instilling values that lead to
self-discovery and self-improvement this
is one of the reasons that I am so
enamored with the founding fathers
despite all of their many and horrifying
sins but they built a system that was
marching it towards self-improvement
that would would literally improve
itself that had massive distrust for
itself that I think is super healthy and
so one of the first things I think
anybody should teach their kids is your
emotions aren't real they are part of
the simulation you need to ask does this
emotion serve
me which of course kids are going to be
like I don't understand what the hell
you're talking about and they're just
emotional creatures But ultimately
that's what you have to March them
towards they need to get control of
themselves Mind Body Spirit and until
they can do that they will run a mug Tom
uh it I want to say for the audience
watching and listening that you're not
just saying this stuff you actually live
it and I know this from experience
because the way you you and I have
always communicated has been on that
basis so just you know giving a little
bit away from behind the curtain we were
sitting next door I we were asking for
some business advice I gave you an idea
of what we're going to do and you were
like yep that's a terrible
idea and you say it in a way that's very
comfortable for me to hear you've said
stuff like that to me before and I've
always been able to take it and use it
because it's useful there's no emotion
attached to it but at the same time
you've told me before that when you were
working in the inner city with people 2%
got it and transformed their lives 98%
did not okay okay why is that the
darkest secret of my life is that I've
given up on
adults and the great irony is I make a
lot of content for adults but I'm making
it for the
2% and I'm doing it as a part of a
bigger strategy and I'm doing it because
of course I love seeing the
transformation of the
2% but if I'm
honest
when the entertainment side of my life
takes off I don't know that I'll keep
doing content aimed at adults because
they're not as
malleable now it doesn't mean that
they're not capable of being malleable
but dude a frame of reference which I
should probably Circle back to so ask me
if you're interested because I might
forget but frame of reference is
brutally difficult to pierce and if you
can't Pierce somebody's frame of
reference they actually do not
understand you well explain that so yeah
that's what I was going to say okay so
frame of reference is your values and
beliefs about what you believe is true
of you and the world and what you
believe ought to be true about the world
and your own behavior people do not
realize that they have made these things
up that they've been given to them by
their parents by the traumas that
they've endured by the country that they
grew up in by the person that was mean
to them in second grade by the time that
they won something whatever like all all
these things that are happening to you
through your whole life are informing to
you the way the world quote unquote is
and the way the world quote unquote
ought to be and they don't recognize
those are all choices all of them and if
they make different choices they will
see the world from a different
perspective now we can get into
post-truth we probably should because
now people are going to say Tom doesn't
think anything is real quite the
contrary I just don't think we're very
good at figuring out what is real and I
think the only way given that our brain
is creating a simulation and that we
only see and are able to interact with a
tiny tiny tiny fraction of what is
actually there and yet we have this
feeling that we see everything we know
everything we got it my feelings they're
real uh that people really don't
understand that that it's all made up
and that you can construct a frame of
reference akaa world viw based on things
you have consciously chosen to believe
because they yield a better result which
to me tells you that you're closer to
ground truth the more you're able to
predict the outcome of your actions the
more likely you are to be close to
ground truth that's why uh Newtonian
physics were never going to give you GPS
Einstein got a little bit closer still
not all the way there but he got a
little bit closer and that gave us the
atomic age and GPS cool so we're getting
closer and we know because it unlocks
abilities cool so that's how I approach
the world I probably am wrong about
virtually everything but the things that
I'm close to being right are the ones
where I can make a hypothesis that makes
a prediction I run a test to test that
prediction and it comes true then I'm
like okay I'm probably pretty close to
ground truth on this one and if you can
get close to um building a frame of
reference that gives you the ability to
be wrong a little bit less than other
people you're moving in the right
direction now the problem is that frame
of reference is completely invisible to
the person that has it unless they're
spending a lot of time like I am really
trying to think I'm probably wrong what
am I wrong about so David Foster Wallace
this is water becomes the perfect
analogy fish do not realize they're in
water and just for like think about how
long humans had no sense of like gravity
is a force and we're just in it and air
is a a substrate and we breathe it like
we just had no sense of it right you're
the last to find out and so that's frame
of reference and so if you can't Pierce
a person's frame of reference and get
them to see for instance I believe you
need tension between the left and the
right now because I believe that I look
at people on the left or the right
screaming at each other and I'm like
you're both wrong but if you feel you
are doing God's work and that God hates
the other side and wants them all to
perish and your job is to kill them and
I say no no no first of all there is no
God and by the way you have to respect
the tension between each other they I am
just another bad person they'll kill you
first yeah so it's like that I won't
make any sense to them and so now that
one's just super obvious um here's an
example from my
marriage my wife used to say hey it's
important to me that you do this and I
was like oh word that means that if I
have time I'll do it because it's
important to her it meant I don't care
if you're talking to the president you
leave that room and you do this thing
and I won't ask you I won't say things
are important more than a couple times a
year but when I do but she never said
that so I was constantly like oh I
didn't get time to do that thing I had
other things to do and she was like what
is happening now we had to actually
articulate those so that we could both
understand each other's frame of
reference she's coming at the world
where if a person says this is important
you drop everything and do it I came
from a perspective of no you have a list
of things that you're trying to get done
you rank order them and then if that's
number three but I don't finish one and
two then of course I didn't do the third
thing so these are such overly
simplified ways I wish in less than an
hour I could actually get to frame of
reference but just know like Einstein
said the most important decision any
human has to make is whether they live
in a friendly or a hostile Universe now
the fact that he called that a decision
tells you everything you need to know
about what a frame of reference really
is because that will color everything
about how you think and act and it also
colors the energy you put out into the
world so if you come in and you think
everybody's hostile you're going to come
in an attack mode because you're going
to think to yourself hang on a second
people are going to attack me I want to
be first and you're going to create more
more more tension as a result and more
battles
100% and which is it just it just shows
how ideology is so powerful and it's
part of the reason or a lot of the
reason why we started this which is if
your ideology is fundamentally negative
and unhelpful and toxic you are going to
live an unhealthy toxic life yeah there
is no doubt and you guys have the very
unenviable position of trying to pierce
other people's frames of
reference it isn't easy but you'll
encounter the 2% who really love an idea
and either they have a conscious or an
intuitive understanding of some ideas
help me make my life better and some
ideas don't help me and so I'm just
trying to collect the ones that are
actually useful if I could even just get
people on to two things Northstar and
usability like was this actually useful
If people could just have a Northstar
now unfortunately some people are going
to have a Northstar that is morally
repugnant can help you there that's
frame of reference but at least if they
articulate what their Northstar is now
we can go oh my God you look and seem
normal but you're really a sociopath or
whoa I actually never considered that
that's a really cool frame of reference
and maybe I'm going to update mine but
if you knew what somebody's frame of
reference was and you thought it was
honorable now it's like we can work
together that's why telling you hey
that's a bad idea only because I know
what your what Your North Star is I know
what you're trying to do and so now I'm
just going to say the reason that's a
bad idea is because it won't do the
thing you think it's going to do and
when you're discussing at that level and
the person does not tie their
self-esteem around being right it
becomes very easy so you just want to
learn you actually care about your goals
which you'll be shocked most people do
not they just care about feeling smart
Feeling Good Feeling respected whatever
uh you actually care about your goals
and yourself esteem isn't tied up and
being right so now it's like yeah it's
very easy to say that won't work here's
the data check it out and by the way if
you show me that I'm wrong I'll
immediately adopt it and update my own
mental model when you have people like
that dude it's a joy and as
entrepreneurs I will just tell you your
job as people that are looking to hire
is that find those people they don't put
their self-esteem around being right and
they are really just trying to figure
out what's effective if you can collect
a group of people like that that are
also hardcore [__] uh you'll
build a smashing business I love it and
I suppose the immediately obvious
question is what is the most useful
frame of reference that you found well
so frame of reference gets really
complicated really fast so I'll give you
some high Lev things uh number one the
universe is completely indifferent so uh
nobody's coming to save you it's not
good or bad right it just it is it
doesn't care right it doesn't care
perfect that's very helpful um Love of
another human being is the greatest
thing that life has to offer
Francis uh and so really taking that
seriously and trying for you guys
watching he's not hitting on it it's
just we were talking about him getting
married or am I uh so yeah I think
especially because I'm such a hustle
porn guy and I'm constantly putting out
the me you need to be hardcore you need
to work harder I never wanted to get
lost that the most important thing in my
life is my marriage why because it's
given me more than anything else
uh so that's super important you can do
anything you set your mind to without
limitation that's a lie but it's an
empowering lie and I only do and believe
that which moves me towards my goals I
call them useful beliefs yeah those lies
perfect so again I say it just because I
know I'm more likely to believe negative
things that are self-defeating just
because that's how the brain keeps you
alive um so since I know that I try to
swing hard in the opposite direction but
look I'm not a fool I know there are
things I'm not going to be able to
accomplish no matter how you could give
me a, years um I almost can't let myself
finish the sentence which is tells you
something about me uh if you gave me a
thousand years I want to believe I could
find a way for humans to fly without the
aid of uh of jets and stuff but uh
anyway it's good to know somewhere in
the recesses of your mind you do have
limitation so you don't do something
stupid but to know that you're way more
likely to stop short out of laziness out
of um fear that you're not good enough
out of just boredom and how hard things
are entropy uh that you probably want to
Cobble together beliefs that push you to
go farther than other people um the idea
that George Bernard Shaw captured in his
quote the reasonable man adjusts the
world the Unreasonable Man insists on
trying to adjust the world to him
therefore all progress um relies on the
unreasonable man that idea like is just
so so so critical and what I find is I'm
not smarter than most people I really do
consider myself pretty average intellect
but I'm really unreasonable and I've
learned when being like super reasonable
is wise and then looking for the like
telltale signs that no there's disaster
ahead and so I should probably back off
a little but I always default to if
somebody tells me this is going to take
uh this is going to take three months
I'll be like we're doing it by the end
of today and just coming in with that
attitude forces you to think in a
totally different way and of course we
don't finish it that day but the number
of times where we've gotten it done in
72 hours when somebody told me it was
going to take three months it's comical
and so um look that's the tip of a very
large Iceberg but at the risk of
rambling uh I'll stop there but I
published a list of 25 beliefs doesn't
cover the value side but the 25 things I
think you need to believe about yourself
in the world uh that will move you
forward and you just type in my name
plus belief system it'll pop up and you
say most adults 98% of adults you you've
got like you could you could give them a
clay tablet with these things and they
just don't want it yeah yeah Clay
tablet's really not going to help you in
fact that might trigger them more
because now you're handing something
down like you know better and they be
like who are you to put something on a
stone tablet yeah you'll get that uh
there's so much cultural energy moving
people often in the wrong direction like
I'll just here's one I was taught to
keep my head down do as little work as
possible and avoid punishment at all
costs but I didn't know that I just
thought that's I just thought that's how
you lived life I did not realize there
were people who did not approach life
that way people are going to hate me for
this some people going to really get
weird about this I had to train myself
that some rules are meant to be broken
and so I started oh you guys are in the
UK this won't be weird for you I started
parking facing the wrong way on the
opposite side of the
street now in the UK you can but here
you get a ticket for it and so if you
see somebody do that as an American you
look at them like who does this guy
think he is like you're not allowed to
do that and I felt so uncomfortable
doing it because I was like who who am I
to think that I can park facing the
wrong way but I was like I have to train
myself that there are some things
there's a reason for them and you don't
do them and then there are other things
where it's like honestly it doesn't
really matter and so I want to remind
myself that uh some rules really are
meant to be broken you have to have that
mentality it will serve you far better
and so doing things like that can be
very useful as ways to puncture your
Fame of reference to realize oh this
really is malleable it isn't me
recognizing the truth of the human
existence it's me having a belief system
and those beliefs are malleable and some
beliefs are more useful at driving me
towards my Northstar Tom it seems that a
lot that we're talking about here comes
down to a few words which is embracing
discomfort where actually we live in a
society and I've made this point
numerous times where we're made Ultra
comfortable we seek Comfort we desire it
but actually where we
grow is in the discomfort and that's
what you're talking about here isn't it
it's being uncom
embracing it because that's how you grow
it's critically critically critically
important so I have a sense that some
people need to be chased by a
lion and that was uh an idea that
occurred to me really early on in my
business life and I just saw people like
spiraling on dumb [__] to get attention
or whatever and I was like you have too
many cycles like spare Cycles there's
the stakes aren't high enough there's
nothing to um slap you back into line
because you can get away with murder and
there's no real consequences like
printing money printing money socializes
losses and it makes it seem like that
thing that we did whatever that may be
wasn't really a big deal but in reality
it's an atrocity and you're going to
have to pay the piper at some point and
so when there's like the lion is chasing
me if I am out of shape and I can't
outrun that lion I get eaten the stakes
are so high and so binary that like you
learn real fast if you have the right
skills or not this is why I like being
an entrepreneur I don't like losing
money but if you're losing money you
haven't done the right thing the market
doesn't care about your product or your
marketing is terrible or whatever and so
every time I do something and it doesn't
work I'm just like I have done something
wrong there is no one to blame but me
and if I don't figure this out I'm going
to go broke that is so sobering and I
love that like I love that just cold
hard reality there's no campaigning to
be done there is only you've either
added value to somebody's life or you
haven't and but there's a lot of people
who spend their time escaping reality
yes yeah okay so now let's see if I can
make you hate me I'm building a virtual
world MH and part of me is
like you better be real careful because
you can really fast become part of the
problem and not part of the solution
so that one's tricky and I think about
that a lot but yes I think that
um I think that it would be very fun to
have a conversation with you gentlemen
about end of Empire Vibes and what is it
that actually happens and I'm going to
guess that things being easy are part of
it and when things are too easy and
we've built too much comfort that
suddenly things that are terrible ideas
don't reveal themselves to be terrible
quickly they reveal themselves to be
terrible slowly and when people push
back the push back on the push back is
going to be what's the harm it's no big
deal because we built in so many buffers
and so it's like I want the buffers the
buffers are amazing but is it I don't
know the answer to this question this is
not me putting forth a a thing where I'm
saying this is true but it does make me
wonder if the reason that history is
this big loop is because you end up
getting into that cycle of uh tough men
create good times good times make weak
men weak men make tough times so on and
so forth and so as you have to harden
again because times are just so bad that
we're like yeah we want the guy with the
iron fist that's going to get everybody
in line and it's just going to make
things okay again I just don't want the
chaos cool and now we get under that
thumb and then we finally fight out from
under that and we get freedoms and oh my
God these are amazing and we get this
Society that's thriving and it's
wonderful but now it's easy and we
devolve again so again I don't know that
that's true but ooh when I look at Roman
Empire and the collapse and like what
happens and things get too good and I
look at some of the things that are
happening now and I'm just like man I
worry I worry that it is
inevitable that would make me sad and I
need to be careful about believing that
because that may not lead me to my North
Star uh but every now and then in I
really dark moments I'm like this is
inevitable I'll lighten it up with a fun
story of how this idea first started
occurring to me I'm 16 and I hear about
Roman orgies for the first time this is
before the internet so I don't have easy
access to pornography but as a
16-year-old male orgies sound pretty
awesome and I'm like wait a second
you're telling me that we had orgies
2,000 years ago but we don't now because
I kind of thought if I just stay alive
long enough because everything's getting
more liberal that by the time I'm 25
orgies are going to be a thing again so
I was like hold on if we've already had
orgies that means that we sort of hit
some sort of hedonistic Peak and then it
dropped back so I'm like time out
because I thought everything was just
one way just more liberal over time more
free sex all the things I wanted at 16
sex drugs Rock Roll sounded awesome and
I was legitimately perplexed with wait
how did we move backwards how did we get
more prudish because my whole life I had
heard oh every day we're getting less
and less prudish as if it were a bad
thing to a six-year-old boy sounded
awesome and yeah so now I'm like wait a
second even though I'm still honestly
I'm for orgies they sound awesome I'm
about it but it could be that that's
also tied to the part of this word all
all things end badly I don't know but
that is uh that's how that exploration
began for
me we'll get back to the episode in a
minute but first we want to tell you
about our sponsor Verso in our recent
interview with Tim Urban he said we
should be talking about longevity and
Longevity science researchers like the
biologist David Sinclair have recently
made some fascinating discoveries on how
to mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that is why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these in incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products I take every
day is called cell beinging cell
beinging helps combat aging by
increasing something called naad Plus in
your body NAD is arguably the most
important molecule in your body high NAD
levels improve your metabolism repair
damage DNA and increase energy
production in your brain immune system
and muscles but as you grow old your
body's NAD levels go down and you can't
take NAD as a supplement because it's
too big for your cells to absorb that's
why Verso cell being contains nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase NAD
plus levels if you want to read more
about this check out the scientific
research Linked In the description of
the video plus Verso publishes third
party testing on every batch of its
product s to guarantee that you're
getting exactly what you're paying for
so if you want to join us you can get
15% off by going to
v.s O that's
v.s o and use code trigger to save 15%
off your order now back to the
interview the printing money we'll talk
on your show about this at length I'm
sure but the printing money thing is
interesting to me because I think it is
the perfect example of what you're
talking about and what Francis was
talking about earlier actually which is
Comfort the reason we print money that
to spend on things we can't
afford is that we are unwilling to be
slightly less comfortable than we
are and then you layer on top of that
the way we do
politics which says if anybody is less
well off as a result of a policy then
you're killing people
this is what people will say right well
if if you if you if you reduce the
amount of spending on public services
you're killing people and you probably
by the way are reducing the number of
people who survive are reducing the
right but now you're into the thing that
freaks me out because it really sounds
terrible but it really may be needed so
it's like I don't know what to do with
that oh uh I mean I know what to do with
that which is people have to live within
the means I I am probably killing you
you you were talking about the fact that
in developing kaisen the video game that
you're working on you probably reduce
your lifespan by 10 years yeah I'm
certainly sure right but you did that
because you want to do something that's
bigger than you is that fair yeah all
true right so what's bigger than me or
what's bigger than us as a society is
the fact that we are impoverishing our
grandchildren that's bigger than me
living longer that's bigger than
anything actually we cannot saddle
people who are not yet born with our
debt because we refuse to be slightly
less comfortable but the political
system that we have prevents that
incentive from being carried through to
its logical conclusion and instead we
have people whose only priority is
coming back to delay gratification right
here right now I'm going to get
reelected right here right now what am I
going to do bribe you with your own
money yeah yeah I I have a because I
know that human nature is knowable even
though it is so complex right now
obviously we're often surprised by it
but it is a knowable thing with enough
compute power we could literally predict
uh based on your genetics your life
experience we could predict what you're
going to do it it is a knowable thing
because it's knowable is why history
Rhymes uh there's just only so many
human responses to things and so Ray
doio has mapped this out and shown how
this cycle just repeats over and over
and over and over and the outcomes are
predictable the buildup IS predictable
and
so again worrying about things being
inevitable I don't know that there's a
way to Stop This Train That's partly why
I Retreat to the individual so my show
is all about what can the individual do
in this time because I'm not trying
Society is an organism that has its own
thing and I don't know that I can stop
it and there's certainly things that are
happening right now that scare me about
what happens when uh the masses start
doing their thing
uh people I forget the quote but it's
like people are amazing but populations
are dumb it's like a mob will kill
murder do things that an individual
human just won't do it really really
scares me like I mean that literally it
scares me and we're in a moment right
now where I can sort of feel the mob
like right at the door uh and we're all
part of that mob that's the other part
is like I put myself in that camp man I
fall into the camp of in history I'm
probably a villain you know what I mean
it's like I do not think oh yeah I'm
sure I would have been one of the good
guys it's like without access to all
these ideas good Lord I could have just
as easily gone there but for the grace
of God go I don't believe in God but I
believe in that statement uh so yeah I
worry about the inevitability of this I
worry that there's no stopping it I
worry that what has to happen is the
only way to do austerity measures is for
there to already be so much pain and
suffering that the austerity measures
are less painful
than what was happening right before
good example of this some people would
argue is Britain in the 70s yeah oh I
was literally thinking of going down the
toilet three three-day week rubbish
piling up in the streets the country is
the sick man of Europe and people get
fed up and they elect somebody who's got
the balls to deal with it yep that's
that's the only
hope she didn't have to deal with a
24-hour new cycle she didn't have to
deal with Twitter
or other social media she did have to
deal with the IRA though I don't know
man I think it's probably easier to deal
with the IRA than
Twitter you know what I'm saying Tak
yeah you know what I'm saying
so that's maybe the that's the only
answer I can see and then and tell me if
it's a terrible idea as you always do
the reason we do what we do I feel and
the reason we're changing from being a
YouTube channel to trigger media where
we have other people working with us and
expanding the the the the scale of what
we do is there has to be a cultural
demand for the supply of a thatcher
likee figure left or right I don't care
what side of the political Spectrum I'm
on there on but it's got to be someone
who has your type of mindset about what
works what doesn't work does it see and
and all of our debates get fra framed
moralistically which is precisely the
problem right because the question for
me
is you know is having an open border as
we do now in the UK and people coming
illegally into the country on small
boats who we don't know where they're
coming from is that working is that
right is that going to improve Society
or is that going to make it worse it's
not about hating the people in the boats
which is what it is always made out to
be it's about is that making our society
better or worse uh is printing money to
buy things we can't afford is that
making Society better or worse is
endlessly amplifying division in society
along racial lines is that does that
work does that make us better that's
always been my frame but we always get
dragged and it's true of both of us too
we always get dragged into the
moralistic side of the conversation how
do we how do we step back from that as a
society can we can we change the culture
probably not so I have a this really is
a hypothesis is not not even making its
way all the way to Theory I ran this
idea I think it was by Heather hying um
do you guys know we had on the show
she's great say she'd be right up your
alley so um I asked her but I don't
remember her answer I said what Fe what
what is happening now feels like um
female hyperaggression
so that we've created a social media
tends to bring this out and because
females tend to lean on that nurturing
side
they are they use reputational damage
and social savagery whereas guys will
just [__] fight and tear you down and
you know all that it's far more direct
super violent uh but it's direct you see
it a lot more and I was like I have a
feeling that what's happening right now
is what happens when you get pathology
in a feminine way of being again I'm the
guy that believes you need both you need
masculine and feminine but if you don't
have them in Dynamic tension you get
this and so social media the reason I
don't know that we're going to be able
to stop this train is again
compassionate ideas spread and we're
just trying to help people all done in
reputational attacks um getting People
cancelled getting people mobbed
ideologically there's a right way to
think and a wrong way to think um
that until you restabilize the dynamic
and I don't know that you can win
there's no threat of violence which
would be the the masculine problem
solving guys so there's okay I don't
know what to make of this but I want to
share something I find utterly
fascinating have you read um the gulg
archipelago of course okay soul jiton
for people that haven't read it read it
I sound way too excited for a book about
a holocaust but uh it's about watch sh's
list you'll have a great time you're
gonna love it there'll be a small
minority that do
mate that's fun uh so it's about for
people that don't know the the ggs in
Russia uh and how people were whisked
away to them and um in it he said that
you know everyone breaks you get
tortured you're going to break for sure
for sure except every now and then there
will be somebody who believes in the
thing they believe in so much they will
sooner let them be tortured to death
than they will break and he said and
every single one of them is a woman and
I was like that holds true with what I
know about my wife
so if the two of us are tortured odds
are I'm going to break my wife on the
other hand if she thinks she's right
forget it forget it she will let you
torture her to death She's just she
can't constitutionally she cannot back
down so anyway you if there is like we
look at these overlapping distributions
men and women are basically the same but
on the edges of the distributions it
gets pretty meaningful and so if you
have this like hyper sense of this is
how the world should be and I will let
you torture me to [__] death I
believe in it that strongly and using
the tools of social media reputation
damage alliances that kind of stuff
instead of like hey you can't talk to me
like that and tell me I'm I'm an idiot
to my face because I might punch you in
yours so guys have a a far more like I'm
going be a little more standoffish
because I know that this may escalate
into a fight women don't approach the
world that way starting to break down a
little bit at the edges which is the
thing that actually makes makes me
uncomfortable but historically speaking
we have a lot of energy that keep it so
that there's a far more sort of savage
approach to relationship damage than
there is to that physical confrontation
side and so in some ways in the age of
social media just going to be a lot
harder to curb that like this one you
could curb with police don't be violent
build a structure around people so
Counterpoint however um and you may
disagree but I when I see the the
breakdown of the mainstream media who
who used to have a a choke hold on on on
the
information what is being replaced by is
this and if the medium is the
message this is a much better medium and
the message is therefore much health it
I want to believe that so badly and I
really don't want to utter these words
but I will because otherwise I feel like
a
coward uh I am terrified to the core of
my existence with what's happening with
um the Israel Palestine conflict as it's
being portrayed on social media and how
quickly people are like no that was a
lie that thing that said was said was a
lie and then it just becomes a what is
true I have no idea what's true and
you're watching in real time people just
just coming out and saying that thing
that was said that you saw the recording
of that wasn't actually said they said
you're like no no no but wait you can
still see it it's right here it doesn't
matter and so I have a a concept that I
hold in my head is velocity of
information and I have a feeling that
velocity of information while it would
be the only thing worse than High
Velocity information is is top down
slowing it down but High Velocity
information allows for confusion allows
for an inability to create a cohesive
narrative that's tied to ground truth
and so what it becomes is bumper
stickers bumper stickers everywhere
bumper stickers and so I follow my
favorite influence who talks in my
favorite bumper stickers the world is
answers they'd rather be at home playing
a video game than thinking about all
that but it feels important to vote so
give me the simplified version so in a
world where velocity of information is
so extreme hopefully Community notes on
X helps I don't know just being a little
pessimistic on this one I I really want
the problem to be solved because it's
worrisome this beautiful thing the
citizen journalist is so amazing and
maybe the blockchain will help us that
would be amazing and so we know like
everything is certified right right that
it's like okay this is real this is
actually what's said it's not spoofed
cuz dude you right now you can go online
and find me speaking Portuguese I don't
speak Portuguese but somebody trained it
on a thousand hours of me speaking so it
sounds like me and then they used AI to
add in the Portuguese and now it
literally sounds like me speaking
Portuguese so the rapidity with which
the 2024 us elections will be inundated
with literal fake imagery is going to be
very
fast that is terrifying the other thing
that I think that is sending us insane
Tom is we go on Twitter and we're
exposed to particularly with the Israel
Palestine conflict horrendously graphic
images that we simply shouldn't be
seeing do you remember when we were kids
growing up or maybe this is a BBC thing
but they always used to say um if you
we're going to show images that some
viewers may find distressing basically
saying to them that if you're of a
sensitive disposition probably not a
good good idea to watch it because this
is quite upsetting but when you go on
social media you just see graphic image
after graphic video after graphic video
after graphic video and then it's into
cut with kittens playing and then you're
back to graphic video so the way your
emotions are getting
manipulated it's it almost feels that
you're on some kind of electronic bumper
cars where you're getting shock After
Shock After Shock
Plus it gives you an unhealthy Rhythm
that then Co that then seeps into the
rest of your day I think that's so
dangerous I don't think we talk about it
enough either yeah I um I I am not of a
weak Constitution and I've I had to just
like set it down man I was like this is
so gnarly like war is gnarly gnarly and
seeing image after image video after
video just yeah it really does mess with
your head you know what I actually don't
don't agree with you guys I really don't
you like to lean into it or think no I'm
not sitting like more of this
but I mean it's a very poignant moment
to talk about this but if you think
about how all of our society has been
shaped in the last 70 years by what we
know about the
Holocaust that was because we were shown
images that no human being really should
ever see but we have to know the truth
of what's going on now
do you need to be consuming that on a
daily basis all day every day no but
when an attack like that happens I'm
glad we saw what happen I think I am too
I I think it's really important that we
saw what happened I agree with all of
that and I'm not saying that people
shouldn't see it and like I said the
only thing that would be worse than High
Velocity information is top down trying
to stop it yeah um which I actually
already am worried about even with the
negative images cuz how quickly they
disappear um but I do think that people
need to be thought thoughtful uh about
how much of that you intake like there
is like I once saw long story I will not
get into on this show uh but a friend of
mine invited me over didn't tell me why
he invited me over and then he said I'm
G to show you a video of a chin Soldier
being decapitated with a handheld knife
and he was basically like I want to see
if you can watch it so I'm like all
right to this day I remember the sights
The Sounds it it really like it can make
my stomach drop now just thinking about
it and the way that that image like
locked itself into my mind I find a
little unnerving because I find it easy
to let go of things so anyway we need to
see what is true we need to face the
truth we need to look at hard things we
need to not be as fatalistic as I've
been at points in this conversation
about thinking things are inevitable and
understanding that we can steer um the
course of history by being better people
etc etc and so I think it is good to
look at it but I also think man be
careful how much time you spend on it it
can be rough yeah well psych everyone's
psychology is different too different
people have different dispositions I I
think there are no Solutions only
trade-offs and social media is one of
the greatest inventions in human history
facts facts facts right you and I
wouldn't be sitting here today none of
the three of us be sitting here today if
it wasn't for that um I mean where that
weighs up against the end of
civilization I don't
it's been a nice chat though yeah look
this has been great as the world Burns
but
um it's interesting it's interesting to
me I think
um I wonder whether a an optimism bias
is nonetheless useful oh for sure you
yeah if you're well okay it's it's at an
individual level if somebody were asking
me I would say yes go towards optimism
you will get more joy out of your life
for sure you will accomplish more for
sure things feel more possible and that
is an awesome feeling but at a societal
level I think it really does take the
dynamic tension again between people
that are like wildly Optimist we can do
anything and people that are like at
some point you actually have to execute
on that and if you thought about this
out or the other so I know in my
business when an idea is fragile I only
want optimistic solution oriented people
when an idea is like fully thought out I
want the pessimistic people to come in
and like really try to find the holes in
the idea so that we can Shore them up at
the idea stage and not when we're deep
into execution so it is good to have
both
sides but as an individual I would for
sure want to be the optimistic one yeah
I guess the ideal is to have but the
both side so when I write comedy when I
I'm in a creative mode I just write
purely and that's all I do I don't limit
I try not to limit I try not to think
about this or that or whatever else or
somebody's done that before I write
right right right right but then you
have the editing process and the editing
is when you're critical the problem is
is when you mix those two processes then
what it is is like putting a car into
fourth gear straight away and it locks
Americans aren't going to get that I get
it I get it I had to drive a stick for
years yeah but do you see what I mean so
both of those processes like you said
are so important the the problem comes
is when you mix the two or when one
becomes more dominant over the other
well said for sure or brother thank you
so much for your time it's a pleasure I
can't wait for us to to be on your show
uh the last question we ask before we go
to locals for questions from our
supporters is what's the one thing we're
not talking about as a society that you
think we should
be for me the core thing is what I was
talking about earlier you're having a
biological experience if I could really
get people to embrace that to understand
their life through the lens of My Body
Works a certain way my emotions a
response to my gut as much as my
thoughts getting all of that Under Wraps
your life will get a lot easier a lot
more predictable and when it's
predictable you're closer to the ground
truth amazing thank you for being here
with us or rather thank you for having
us here no that was awesome I really
enjoyed it yeah what a what a
conversation what have you landed on
foodwise and fasten durations that gives
you the greatest results from energy in
clear mind to better sleep or are you
still
experimenting
[Music]